alhamdulillah
[Silence]
Quan
Quran
subh
[Silence]
We are
continuing in the chapters regarding the
Miracles performed by the prophet
sallallah alai wasallam these
Miracles were performed in his time and
they are to Allah's
discretion and Allah subhanahu waala he
is the one who performs them as for all
of the prophets and Messengers every
prophet and messenger comes with
overwhelming evidence that they have
been sent by Allah subhanahu wa taala
it's that just one thing here or one
thing there overwhelming
evidence overwhelming evidence means
that when you look
into any book that the prophet has been
sent with whether it is the
original or
the or thean or the legislations of the
prophets there's many things that are
taken into account in order to determine
the
legitimacy of his prophet phood one
of the greatest of those evidences and
something that
you usually only
see with regards to
prophets is that all of
humanity essentially
agrees
that this was a
prophet what do I mean by that I mean
that Allah
waala has made for instance the message
of he has made his message and his the
events that transpired with
Isa overwhelming to the point where our
calendars are based on his alleged birth
this is all of history is written
based on that event of his birth ad and
BD before death and after death Etc
these are all indicators that this was a
prophet a messenger from Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
taala the fact that someone could have
had such
notoriety time thousands of years
ago
and this notoriety be of such
ensity that all of humanity knows who
this person is all of humanity 2000
years later 3,000 years later regardless
of their religion they know who this
person is this is something that is
reserved for the prophets and The
Messengers and then on the other hand
you find people
who their mention is preserved their
history and they are notable simply
because they cross paths with the
prophet or
messenger even if it is in a bad way
perhaps for instance Pharaoh the
Pharaoh of
Moses is
beyond why because he he
played serious part in the message of
M and so this
person's mention has been preserved it's
not preserved in a good way but it is
preserved simply because of the event of
this Prophet this messenger that was
sent to
humanity
[Silence]
s
forl
[Silence]
for
s
noi mentions here he says that as far as
Miracles that were performed by the
prophet s. wasam aside from the Quran
the Quran is the Pinnacle of his
miracles that he was given actually the
Quran is the Pinnacle of all miracles
and all
books that Allah subhah wa taala has
revealed to
humanity and for that reason the
Quran
is the book by which
others will be judged meaning that the
Quran will be a testimony being that the
Quran is the words of Allah will be a
testimony on the day of
judgment against or for previous
Nations and
that this nation the nation of Muhammad
s. wasallam will be the first nation to
enter
Paradise though it was the last Nation
TimeWise likewise the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam will be the
one
who
who makes the ultimate
intercession on behalf of all of the
human being and gen kind on the day of
Jud judement as the narrations are very
clear with regards to and Allah
subhanahu Waal
[Silence]
says
and so aside from the Quran
the number
of prophetic Miracles that he brought
it's not possible to completely
enumerate all of
them and when we think of a miracle
usually we think of something
immediate that happens that is
extraordinary that occurs the sea
splitting for
M or the dead speaking or coming
back to life
with and there there are lots of
instances of that in the prophet Sall
alam's history however there are other
more subtle
Miracles such such as his
character such as that the incredible
amounts of
pressure that he s. wasam
experienced in his 23 years of
prophethood yet somehow was able to bear
that pressure and to only become more
adamant about his message as time went
on the consistency of his
message this is an important point the
consistency of his
message when we look
at any person who claims that they
are a prophet any person who claims to
be a
prophet the prophet Muhammad s. wasam
came to the
people and
said I have been sent as a Warner to you
all I am proceeding and being followed
by a great punishment if if people do
not obey his
message when people start like
this when when if we look through
history we look at false prophets people
that claim to be prophets and they were
not
prophets or we look at cult
leaders very similar because a cult
leader usually begins in this way Begins
by L leeching on to some other person
before him they'll have a church for
instance or they'll have a synagogue or
they'll have a a temple that people will
come to
and he usually it is
men male will start to become more and
more
radical and more and more
different and more and more
trying to raise himself in the eyes
of his followers and usually this ends
up with them claiming to be God or
claiming to be divine or claiming to be
a messenger of God
Etc so it starts out with I'm just a
regular guy I'm you right just
starts out as a a preacher or a
pastor and then it continues to change
that I'm not just a pastor I'm actually
a prophet I'm actually a messenger I'm
actually God incarnate and so forth
because as time goes
on they lose their consistency now
they are demanding more and more
reverence from their
followers and this happens within a few
years it's not something that is very
gradual most of the time you could see
that a good example of that is
in our modern time for instance Jim
Jones some here will remember Jim Jones
is from Indiana
originally he founded the People's
Temple and this was in
California in a time when racism was a
real thing and
while you know the africanamerican the
black community was no longer
umed
slaves to Masters they still were
very majority of people were
very very U very against having them
around mixing mingling with them they
had to sit in different seats in the bus
and they had to drink from different
fountains they were completely
segregated and what was unique about him
is that when he started the people's
Temple he allowed all
Races into his church right he was a
preacher allotted all Races into his
church black span Hispanic Latino
whatever all of them were welcome
and this was extremely rare usually
different races have their
different and as time went on he became
more and more radical in
his
ideas and become more and more radical
in his demands of his
followers and when he began to see that
he could not comp
completely take the amount of reverence
that he wants from his followers he has
to isolate them he took them and they
all went to South America in the middle
of the Jungle country called Guyana and
it's place there they built this little
village in the middle of nowhere it's
still there it's called
Jonestown
and you know this cult started
to somewhat Thrive they made they
planted their own food they harvested
their own food Etc but he became more
and more
unhinged as time went
on and people would be punished for
disobeying him and people would be put
to shame and sexual devian is kind of a
given in Cults right and as time went on
they became more and more violent and if
a person wanted to leave
this person would not be able to until
it became so much so that he
had
speakers throughout this
Village and he would have tapes of
recordings of his sermons being played
247 all of the time day and
night loud so that anybody who wakes up
or goes to sleep this is what listening
to all of the
time and eventually he coerced many of
his followers in the hundreds
to mass suicide the point is is that you
can trace this man's
claims throughout his time he starts as
just a humble servant who's a little bit
different than the rest and turns
into this monster at the end that claims
to be divine mind claims to be receive
Revelation from God claims to be a
messenger or a prophet
Etc when we look at the message of
true prophets we see consistency all the
way
through
so at the beginning of his messenger
ship at his prophethood he will say I am
merely a servant of Allah sent to teach
you how to worship Allah and to Garner
his favor and no matter how much time
transpires 60 70 80
years 250 years
after an entire
Millennium his message is still the same
it never changed it never developed into
more as the person becomes more and more
greedy and more and more
you know demanding of people's
reverence and at the beginning of his
messengership when he was first sent as
a prophet what did he say I am a man
just you I have received Revelation
I'm a prophet of Allah a humble servant
of Allah etc etc after 950 years the
message is still the same I am a a human
being you
are the only difference is that
Revelation comes to me and I deliver to
you the messages of
Allah this consistency is only found in
prophethood this kind of consistency is
only found in
Revelation because people all change
they have to change based on their
environment the time their age how they
feel people change they cannot remain
consistent in that way the only thing
that is consistent is
revelation
say
subh that which translates
to why don't they contemplate the Quran
deeply reflect on it and they would
arrive at the conclusion that if this
book if this Revelation was from other
than Allah they would find much
discrepancy in
it human beings are
naturally they naturally naturally
contradict themselves they will no
matter what their willpower is they will
change the way they see the world over
time and when this is Guided by
revelation we call this
wisdom and when this is not Guided by
revelation we call this senility person
become scile they start to
change and the things that they've been
repressing starts to come to the surface
as they lose control over
time miracles of the Prophet s. wasam
that are more subtle and arguably more
compelling such as his generosity for
instance
[Silence]
the prophet sallallah alai wasallam said
if I had a mountain of gold the size
of day and night would not pass over
this mountain of gold except that I
would completely deplete it giving it in
charity for the sake of Allah subhana
waala mean if you just
imagine how
much Manpower it would take to Simply
get rid of a mountain of
gold eyes
of and he swears by Allah that if he
were allotted such riches such
Treasures 24-hour period would not
transpire but that it would be
completely gone none of it to
himself these are the sentiments of a
person who is sent by Allah subhanahu
waala these are not the sentiments of
a person who
is a liar a person who is a
charlatan and the list goes on the
prophet s. wasam we can see that with
time as if he became even more
humble than he was in the
beginning and as we said that is exactly
the opposite of a charlatan a person who
claims to be a prophet and is not will
become more and more arrogant and more
and more unhinged with time and we could
see that and for that
[Silence]
reason
can muham
[Silence]
Alam
subh
and so it is of the wisdom of Allah
subhanahu
waala that in the same time that the
prophet Muhammad s. wasam was
sent
that people from all over started to
claim prophethood as
well we
have we
have even a
woman that claim to be a
prophetes during his
time and we see the me the message that
they allegedly brought they tried to
make up verses for themselves they
tried to make their own
Quran some of them even tried
to Ally with one
another you're a prophet so and this
woman who claims she's a prophet they
got married right to try to unite
forces and we see how Allah subhanahu
waala raised the prophet s. wasam and we
see that the only reason the only
reason that we still know the names of
these people is that they crossed paths
and were enemies of the Prophet Muhammad
s. wasallam that's the only reason no
accomplishment in their
life no contribution to humanity the
only
reason that their name has been
documented that their name is still
alive is because they cross paths with
the prophet Muhammad s
this is how powerful his message is when
we see things this a good
[Silence]
example
subh
[Silence]
r
e
Muhammad these are more subtle miracles
of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam but if you if you study them
they become more
impactful than other more readily
apparent
miracles of the Prophet sallallah alai
was so for instance the moon was split
in his time people saw this this is an
incredible miracle that can't be denied
and it can't be refuted or argued away
it can't
be but we weren't there to see that we
only have people who were there that
told us about
it but if we look at the prophet
sallallah Ali wasam at some of the
narrations the
audacity of his
message that he would sit in a little
tiny spot in the middle of
nowhere in his Masid in Medina the
ground is just dirt and Pebbles the
walls are barely holding up they're made
out of mud and Clay they have to be
repaired every time it every time it
rains the ceiling is not there there
is no ceiling except in the very front
and it is just some leaves that
are put together from date palms to keep
the
sun off of the
worshippers he's sitting on this little
mimar this little Pulpit of three
steps and they're in a state of famine
and they are hungry and they are
scared there
are every
other people around them is looking to
eradicate them they barely have
any alliances with
anyone seems that as divided as people
were one thing they could all agree on
is that the prophet Muhammad sallam and
his companions are a
problem them
and in spite of those circumstances he
sits in
this under these
circumstances and he sits there in the
Masjid and tells his
companions this religion will reach
wherever day and night reach on this
Earth that's a very Auda audacious
statement it's not he made this
statement after the conquest of Mecca or
in the time of Omar or in the when the
Muslims you know essentially conquered
the world no he made this in the in the
depths of of these circumstances when
things seem they couldn't be worse
and they couldn't be harder and they're
so hungry that they're tying stones to
their stomachs and his companions are so
hungry that they are falling down
senseless from
malnourishment that he makes this
statement
a very audacious
statement and with time it only rings
more and more
true this is an incredibly
compelling
argument for the it's an irrefutable
argument for
the
legitimacy of the Prophet
Sall Muhammad's message from Allah it is
legitimately from Allah sub wa that is
not something that can be explained
away if you look at the statements that
Allah makes in the
Quran statements of
challenge in which Allah
subhah says if all the human beings and
all the Gin kind all
collaborated and helped one another they
would never be able to produce a Quran
this it's a very aous
statement yet we see that that is
exactly the case and it's it's been
attempted many times even in modern
times these kinds of things are not
something that a charlatan will say why
because charlatan is always afraid he's
going to be found
out you ever see Allah subhanahu wa tala
tells us for instance
[Silence]
in
subh
[Silence]
Allah subhah wa ta'ala tells us for
instance
inah
he describes the prophet s.
wasam as not at all withholding with
regards to the revelation of Allah he is
not
withholding what's that mean he's not
withholding this was one of the
evidences that Allah subhanahu wa taala
presented as an argument for the
legitimacy of the Prophet Muhammad's
message
what is that argument the argument is if
you go for instance if you look at
people claim to be
psychics right they don't ever come out
and say something very clear that
everyone can understand is
unambiguous and irrefutable that never
happens is that lying anything that they
do are privy to it's just a drop in an
ocean so they have to mix it with with
lies and make up this big act right so
instead of telling you for instance
the person you know so and so name the
person no they'll just start with a
letter I'm seeing the letter d d anybody
in your family has a name starts with d
maybe a distant friend well what are the
chances of that most people have someone
in their
family who's named with name that has
the letter D in it I mean that's right
and then they feed off of what you give
them you ask them a very clear question
they can't tell
you why because they're afraid if they
say something too
explicit not open to interpretation and
they're wrong that's it their whole
argument falls
apart but they'll only give you little
pieces here and there the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when you go
to him you don't find that
behavior the behavior is recitation of
chapters that are hundreds of verses
long making audacious claims with total
impunity this will happen this will not
happen these are the statements of a
king not even a messenger of Allah can
make these statements independently
these are the words of the king of kings
subhanahu waala this kind of audacity
and when you read the
Quran you have a sense to it a
feel that these are not the words of a
human
being even if it's just translation
translating some of the meanings of the
Quran if it's
translated with any amount of accuracy
impossible possible for a person to
imagine that these are the words of a
human being you
can't and for this reason even the
prophet his his his enemies said well
you know he has he he's
he has you
know so you know he's he's got some
affiliation with the Jin human beings
can do this Jin are coming to him and
bringing him this these
verses and so these are incredibly
compelling
arguments sometimes and sometimes we as
Muslims we almost don't behave in a way
that articulates this total acceptance
of the Prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam
message every time we hear
something new we have to look at it some
some new narration it's we have to
look at it with some kind of Suspicion
is it really and then scientifically is
that true is this really his
words yes these are the words of a
messenger of Allah the
companions they didn't have this problem
when they believe they entered in belief
that's it he's above approach and
question now he's a messenger of
Allah he doesn't have to continuously
prove himself to us and prove the
validity of his prophethood every time
we hear his
narrations every time we hear the
Quran and if I don't understand it could
this be the weak link no there is no
weak link if a person truly sits down
and is honest impossible to come to any
other
conclusion I mean seriously
with all of what Islam
is the claim that he was not a
prophet leaves much more impossibilities
and unanswered questions that causes
more
conflict all of this makes sense if he
was a messenger of
Allah if he was not and we have a lot of
explaining to do where did this Quran
come from why are his followers so
adamant and
devout why is that we don't see that in
any other
religion this is this is problematic now
a person who makes that claim who says
no he was not a prophet he owes us an
explanation for all of these unanswered
questions he was not a pro how is the
book that he brought completely
preserved in this way
how how did that happen not even one dot
one letter changed over 1500 years years
how is that
possible how is it possible for us to
still have chains of
narration how is it possible that his
words are so well documented how is it
possible that his followers are so
devout and
numerous
Allah